but yeah we've just come back from our
christmas holidays uh which is i i think
this was one of the first christmas
holidays that actually felt like a
christmas holiday
right because uh normally christmas
holiday is like the busiest time of the
year for me because i'm trying to get
like my end of year video out and then i
don't know what switched in my mind to
make me realize what if i just
don't do that and uh give myself some
time off and then i put the video out
sometime next month god discovers the
word no
for the first time it's like taking a
break yeah i can say that now wait a
minute what you mean the expectations
were just all in my head
and no one really cares if i just delay
the video for like a few weeks never
trust anyone not even yourself
you mean i was my own worst enemy
i i feel uh one i'm just recovering from
being sick so if i'm a little quiet
doesn't have to come over don't worry
about it yeah i'm negative boys i'm also
negative in life i'm always negative
you just described yourself right the
negative person i'm just negative like
what happened like you had like a sore
throat or something yeah i had like a
really bad sore throat and then it just
kind of went and that now i'm in like
the last days where i still sound sick
but i feel totally fine okay yeah
but you were sipping that manuka honey
up there though yeah yeah absolutely
manuka honey is fine it is
it just costs an arm and a leg yeah
that's the problem it's like it's like i
remember i saw the other day it was like
a job this big of manuka like that it
was like 60 bucks what is manuka honey
it's it's this plant right there no no
it's it's a type of honey made from a
certain i think species of bee that's
only found in new zealand i know it's
new zealand yeah yeah it's a key it's
like a kiwi bee basically and it's like
it's like halfway between i remember
because i saw like a whole business
insider video on this yeah it's like uh
yeah because they did like uh you know i
thought they pollinated something like
really specific like this
this is the honey that's spunked on this
i'm sure it's something like the bee you
know takes the pollen from like a
specific plant and only makes honey out
of that or something like that but yeah
it's uh i know it's like a kiwi thing
and the reason is because like just the
whole process of it is really long yeah
and arduous and also it's like halfway
between like royal jelly and honey i
think yeah that's that's how it kind of
works i don't know i don't know i always
recommend it it's really hard to
recommend because people like you're
paying how much for a jar of honey can i
not just buy honey
that's just normal
when you you know when you pour honey it
pours the like manuka honey stuff
doesn't pour it's like molasses
like a block and like i normally like if
i scream a bunch i'm doing a lot of
voice acting yeah i'll normally just
take a little teaspoon not fill it up
just like a little bit i'll just eat it
yeah yeah i don't know a lot yeah i
don't know why because there are a lot
of like products that are very expensive
and i'd say that they're not that much
different from like the base product
like manuka honey versus normal honey
but manuka honey i don't know what it is
i don't know if it is a placebo but it
could be people it could be a placebo
every time every time i've taken some
it's like my sore throat just
immediately goes away yeah i mean i mean
it's that whole thing of like are you
wearing a product or are you wearing a
brand yeah i think right when it comes
to like clothes for example yo are these
bees like minted by louis vuitton like
what's going on here if you look really
close on the side of the body it says lv
they're like branded with lv
oh [ __ ] the bees coming in with like the
drip jacket like hello they come to the
farm hello i'm here to pollinate you
um
okay it's the plants wearing the [ __ ]
drip jackets should have it should have
been more aggressive i don't know
i disagree
half this podcast is that doesn't sound
right but my my manuka honey knowledge
isn't enough to dispute you or dispute
you on that people have google yeah
because because i've tried like a bunch
of things like i've tried like you know
that
really expensive pink himalayan salt oh
yeah
like the most of the cost goes into
like mining this [ __ ] song because
it's like one of the rare assault was
one of the hardest salts to mine durian
they shout out my supermarket huh they
sell it at my supermarket do they
actually yeah i've got something it's
like
i don't know if it's it's probably not
really
probably like it's like two bucks it's
definitely not sea salt with pink dye on
it there's probably sea salt pink dye it
says himalayan salt on it got it for
like 150 yen yeah
that ain't right
about you
know
i actually tried the second most
expensive i think it's the second most
but it's one of the most expensive
coffee beans in the world yeah right
which is how they harvest this coffee
bean is i believe it it's like this is
the tattoo one the the cat poop yeah
we've seen the bucket list all right
we've seen the movie we know wait what
that's why i became like really popular
because in the bucket list there was
like a whole this whole big joke in the
movie was the fact that he didn't know
this expensive coffee this rich guy was
buying from poop down which uh which
film was this the bucket list
with morgan freeman and uh jack
nicholson oh that one okay i don't know
i don't know why i know that maybe i've
never seen it i don't know i just know
it's that like
i thought you were just talking about a
a bucket list
a
default this is why their coffee became
so well known
because in this well it was obviously it
was it was a thing before right right
yeah it was a massive part of the movie
was a big joke that this guy was like he
was like i have to have this coffee and
he didn't know this whole time that he
was eating like cabbage
that was pooping it out yeah
it's not actually cats it's not it's a
kind of like it's like an animal right
like a mouth like a big joke in the
movie is that he's eating the poop beans
and he's like
what i'm more surprised of the fact that
they talk about that in the bucket list
is the fact that you've seen the bucket
list what do you mean it's a it's an
amazing film i don't know you're the
only
i know who's seen it jack dickson and
morgan freeman are you going to sit and
tell me you don't want to watch it it
was like it was one of those movies that
i saw
like in my oh i'm [ __ ] dating myself
here i saw my local blockbuster back in
the day oh my
it was one of those ones that was always
on that like highlighted shelf of like
these these are the talked about movies
right now it was always smack bang in
the middle it was like [ __ ] jack
nicholson morgan freeman don't like that
like that kind of face just says the
bucket list
that looks boring why did not watch the
bucket list i don't know it just never
interested me
i didn't even know about it until now
it's very good how did they react to it
in the movie he was like shocked
obviously and distraught that he'd been
eating did he enjoy it did he enjoy the
coffee what was it yeah good coffee no
so he didn't he he was obsessed with
this coffee i don't know where it was
from right and because jack nixon in the
movie plays a very wealthy man he has
all the money in the world and morgan
freeman is in the same hospital room as
him and it has no money yeah it's this
whole joke of morgan freeman's like oh
by the way i found out about those beans
that you like so much the cats poop them
out and then it's like haha
rich man eats poop
that was it was that the tagline for the
movie yeah
it's a very good movie i'm not selling
you on it but it's really good
man rich man needs boobs that's telling
me
sells a movie
[Laughter]
oh my god yeah i mean i i tried it and
it was just uh
sydney gave it to me and sydney was like
making this massive like ceremony about
how it's the biggest [ __ ] deal on it
i've had it before as well when it's
like it's a good cup of coffee it's a
good cup of coffee but it's it is like
to die for no i'll be honest i can tell
would i put it on when i put it on my
bucket list probably i don't know how
much sydney like uh grinded when she
made our cups of coffee because when she
made our cups of coffee it was like i
had three x like a triple espresso or
something we insane we're just like
sitting in our chairs being like honey i
know it's christmas but uh i think i
need to like go out and go for a run
like i just had so much energy that i
couldn't even think straight oh my god
it's the poop it's the poop it's the
food what is it about poop because i was
i was actually researching this right
well we just did not talk about poop but
of course scott somehow brought it up
trashed it's trash taste of course you
were researching poop okay yeah i was
because i because after that i was
researching the coffee right and
that used to be the most expensive
coffee
in the world i assume because of the
bucket list but now there's a more
expensive coffee uh which is based on
elephant poop and it comes from thailand
and i'm just like
what is it what is up with
what's stopping me from ingesting coffee
beans pooping them out and then just
putting the highest price tag on it
let's see the sea dog for yeah c-dog
expressway
i've actually seen a japanese youtuber
do that no no actually no way
no way it was it was absolutely
disgusting
i'm not going to describe the video oh
you know you get a sense of the idea why
did he sell it no he didn't sell it he
was afraid to drink it he got his friend
to drink it
yo you're eating you're drinking my [ __ ]
you're drinking my [ __ ] your trash
tastes
tastes special i don't know i don't know
how that's on youtube yeah